So, we need one more thing to
finish mean shift tracking.
You remember before,
when I was showing you the mean shift
example we were plopping down a circle,
right, and I said we'll worry
later about the shape of that?
Well that circle can be thought
of as a uniform kernel.
What I mean by uniform is that its
height is the same everywhere around and
it happens to have a circular shape and
it would be written like that.
That's not such a great kernel, what
do you think a better kernel might be?
Well, instead of using uniform kernel
we could use something that is
differentiable, we'll use that in
a minute, isotropic, all that means is
that it's the same in every direction,
monotonically decreasing kernel and
there's a certain convexity property
we're not going to worry about that.
So, so what's our favorite
differential isotropic monotonically
decreasing always positive kernel?
Yes, it's the Gaussian.
Okay.
So here it's written just as a constant
proportional to a fall off by
the square of the distance, okay?
You can also have a scale factor, right?
So if you wanted you could talk
about like, the sigma, sort of the,
the scale of the kernel.
What's really cool about this is that,
unlike the uniform kernel, which goes
straight and then falls off on the edge,
this is differentiable, okay?
You can know how much it's changing, and
it also means that it goes
down to zero at the edges.
So as you slide that kernel along a new
point, it just has a very, very small
weight, in fact, an infinitesimally
small weight, and then it grows.
Likewise, points that are right near the
top, their weight doesn't change very
much, right, because as you slide it
along, the weight stays about the same.
The points that are going to have
the greatest value are the ones that
are along the slope.
What that means is,
you can know how your function
changes as you move,
that is your overall function.
So, your coefficient for example,
and what you can do is, you can use
this gradient to essentially hill climb
up your similarity function, right?
So you can, by computing this, you
don't have to sort of blindly search,
you actually follow that gradient and
get to a local maximum.
All right?
And that was the basis
of mean shift tracking.
So now, going back to our, our previous
example here of the ping pong, right,
we start with the, the current frame.
We want to search, but
now our search can actually climb
to the maximum of this function,
using that gradient information,
and that's mean shift tracking.